now i would like to
welcome today's presenter associate
professor
professor michael bernstein michael
um the associate professor in computers
of computer science in the stanford
and the stanford school of engineering
is also a fc microelectronics faculty
scholar at stanford
where he is a member of the human
computer
interaction group his research focuses
on the design of social computing and
crowdsourcing systems
michael has received eight best paper
awards
at premier computing venues and he has
been recognized with an
nsf career award and an
alfred peace loan fellowship his phd
students have gone on both to
industry working at adobe facebook and
starting
companies as well as faculty careers at
carnegie mellon and uc berkeley
michael hole holds a bachelor's degree
in symbolic system from stanford
as well as a master's degree and phd
in computer science from mit
welcome everyone today and welcome
michael
would you please go ahead and get
started all right
it's wonderful to have you all here uh
thank you anita my name is michael
bernstein as
she mentioned and yeah i teach in and do
research in stanford's computer science
department which
means that i'm interested in how we
design computational systems that are a
better fit for
human needs goals uh and and
essentially the broader context and a
lot of what we do
draws on the techniques developed by
modern artificial intelligence
algorithms
to create new kinds of user experiences
and that's really what our goal is going
to be today we're going to be thinking
about
the kinds of opportunities that arise
when you combine
ai with human computer interaction or
hci
but also the the unique challenges that
come and i want to start off by just
mentioning
that you know if we get this wrong there
it can be really
really tough i'm sure you've all seen
examples public publicized on
in the media uh demonstrating
uh for example when people are applying
ai techniques in ways that are
uh racist biased are are creating all
sorts of errors
even today on the internet lots of
people i think uh chiding a website that
will tell you uh the gender of a name
and putting in words like
you know professor and finding out that
it's 90 percent nurses
is very female there's lots of
challenges and issues that we have to
consider
as we as we think about these about
these and i think it's important that we
that we draw on broad stakeholders when
we're doing this today we're going to
focus on
how ai is influencing sort of that last
mile of user inter
interaction uh so i'm going to go ahead
and share my screen which means that
my face is going gonna largely disappear
but i have i promise i am talking to you
live and uh i
encourage you to put questions into the
q a and i'm happy to have a conversation
about this as as we wind up so again
very thrilled you're here with us you're
gonna get a brief moment of transition
as we start the slides this talk is
going to be about what i call
interactive artificial intelligence
so i think what we need to do here is
acknowledge that
that ai is not just a thing that happens
in the back end that but that ultimately
these are all done in the service of
some
human goal and sometimes they're there
these ai systems are put directly in the
hands
of people and we need to think about how
we co-design the ai
and the interaction to be effective
now give a few examples um
here on the line on the right from from
colleagues at uc berkeley
showing that you know really ai hits the
road
when it starts to interact with people
whether we're talking about
um in these examples robots robots that
are
uh you can imagine a completely
non-humanoid robot but at the end of the
day
the robot needs to interact with people
so what these folks on on the left at
mit's personal robotics group are doing
are looking at ways in which robots are
giving social cues
through through uh what it's looking at
for example that people can make sense
of
or on the right uh on dragon's group at
uc berkeley is building
grass uh grasping algorithms that people
can understand they're legible they're
that i can predict where that robot is
going to actually grab
because it turns out that the most
direct path for a robot to grab
say that bottle on the right on the
right-hand side
is not actually the path that people are
going to find the most intuitive
so instead the robot can take a less
direct path but one that people make
more sense and can predict what it's
going to do
now we already have ai that's
interactive in everyday use
um maybe you use siri or alexa
or any of these uh these smart
assistants or maybe you just use
uh systems like google bing other search
engines
and those are all ais behind the hood
they are ais that have been built with
the interaction
on top of them google very famously
created just a single text box whereas
previous search engines were much more
complex
and at the end of the day i think we
have to acknowledge
that automation here is not the answer
that um actually a very good case in
point as i'm speaking my alexa is
actually talking to me because it thinks
i'm trying to address it
i just had to go unplug my alexa right
now because
uh it has not been designed effectively
to take into account that i might be
talking about
alexa rather than to alexa so case in
point
automation full automation is not the
answer i think a very
uh simple case in point here is is uh
self-driving cars
we've i would love it to be the case
that i could get into a car
and that it would just get me where i
need to go but a ton of studies have
demonstrated that this is a really
patently bad idea
what you're seeing here is uh some some
some moments from
a study done by wendy joo who's now at
cornell tech
looking at handoffs between automation
and live human control every car every
automated car at
some point is going to get into a
position where it no longer can drive
completely out in an automated way
there's construction on the road it's
confused it needs to hand control back
to the human
and in the bottom left you can see this
person is actually staring at their
phone while they're getting driven
somewhere here in a simulator
uh and then the car all of a sudden says
oh guess what it's your turn now
and the person freaks out um and
and barely avoids careening off the road
in fact there's another cars coming in
as oncoming traffic they almost get into
a uh
into an accident they're also swearing
um i've i've cut that part out
and essentially it's not about is the
automation good or is the person good
but here it's that intersection where
the automation had to hand back off to
the person
how do we design those those seams
so that people can work more
collaboratively and that the power can
be handed back and forth more
effectively
and to make this point i'm going to
start by introducing a term
it's called intelligence augmentation
and it actually has a long
history intelligence augmentation i
think
effectively understood as a response
notion that
everyone's just um there are many folks
including actually stanford has incoming
faculty erin yolsen he was just uh
arriving from mit uh studying
which jobs in particular ai might
actually eventually displace
and they're largely very rote ones and
in reality
um there are there are some jobs that
that will be replaced in that way
but many are it's going to be the
story's going to be much more
complicated
and it's there's going to be more much
more of a pull and tug
so this is a picture of douglas
engelbart he's a touring award winner
that's basically the nor the nobel prize
of computer science uh douglas engelbart
invented uh among many things hypertext
the mouse
um a two-handed uh one-handed key uh key
chord
uh corded key set which we use less
the the initial word processor all sorts
of stuff effectively
you know the first working graphical
user interface
um but he had a vision around how all
this was going to go
one which he published at stanford
research institute sri at the time
about what he called augmenting human
intellect that computers were not here
to replace us but to actually make us
smarter
imagine a sort of cognitive prosthesis
something that's like a strap-on cortex
that
makes our brains smarter
and i think you can sort of see these
two ideas as being a little bit in
tension
on the left artificial intelligence
where you're trying to take human
intelligence and just replace it with
computation
on but on the right and i think the the
point i'm going to try to make here
is much more focused on what i would
call intelligence augmentation and what
douglas engelbart calls intelligence
augmentation
where instead of just displacing what
you're doing is actually using the
computation and the intelligence
to help us do think through things
smarter better
more effectively more collaboratively
now any story about
what ai and interaction are going to do
together needs to start with a very
brief
uh collective moment of what ai can and
cannot actually achieve
and here i love this quote by etan adar
at university of michigan where he says
don't let your ui
your user interface write a check that
your ai can't cache
what he means by this is that
it's very common that people will build
user interface elements
that assume an a an ai that's smarter
than ai can actually
provide i think one of the most famous
examples of this um
if i'm not going to raise various forms
of ptsd for
for old-time computer users is clippy
the microsoft office assistant
i was trying to guess when you were say
writing a letter and would pop in a
little paper clip and say
hey it looks like you're writing a
letter but the ai they had tuned it down
to the point where it was
not really very smart and so the user
interface was brill was you know
assuming a brilliant ai that didn't
actually exist so how do we know what
might actually be feasible
my colleague andrew ing in computer
science is a machine learning researcher
i think had this article in the harvard
business review that i think puts a nice
point on it
um you know we can debate the
particulars of it but i think in broad
brush strokes this is this is not so far
off
that we have to think about two things
first essentially when you're talking
about ai
almost all of its progress is through a
particular type of function
something that takes some input a and
generates some simple response
b and the a's and the b's can change but
it's always a becomes b
you give it an a that's a picture and
the b response is a yes or no is there a
face in it
you give it an a that's a loan app and b
is a prediction will they repay it
again there's lots of issues with doing
that and bias um
that can come out of it a is uh might be
an english phrase b might be a french
phrase we're just translating everything
sort of
uh you feed something in it gives you
something back
and what he says that i think is is a
good way of thinking about this is that
if a tip
if a typical person can do a mental task
with less than one second of thought
then we can probably automate it using
ai either now
or in the near future so what does that
mean
right it means that things like is that
a person is that a face is that a dog
is that um is this sentence in english
um all of these kinds of tasks are
things that
you do almost subconsciously very
quickly in a second or less
and they vary obviously if not already
can be done by ai
other things like please design this
software for me
architect my home um is this
is this person going to win the olympics
in
in 10 years these are all things that
would take much more than one second of
thought
um and so this is likely to remain
outside
of the realm of ai for for the
considerable future
so again is my car inside the lane
yes we can do that now that's a very
fast task um
but is is my
harsher we can make judgments but maybe
maybe
uh we're doing okay but we're not it's
not clear we're going to get it right
yet
so then we need to flip this around say
okay if that's if that's what a i can
and cannot do
what can and then can't we do with with
intelligence augmentation
and here i'll give you a few examples of
how um
how things that are likely coming to
market soon
um are drawing on these these advances
so you can imagine for example um a
project in which
a piece of hardware that you can install
just sort of uh
turn some turn something into the pipes
outside of your the spigot outside of
your house
and it will start to disaggregate your
water pressure
your water usage and be able to start
telling you how much water is being used
by this toilet this bathtub this sink
this dishwasher
imagine just being able to screw one
thing in and then getting all sorts of
visualizations
uh about what's using water right it's
learning on
it's learning on its own it's being
trained what's a toilet what's a faucet
and the way you can tell this is by
momentary changes in the water pressure
in your in your water line
as some as say the faucet opens
and once you have these you can start to
think about how you design
potentially behavior change interfaces
that would visualize how much water
you're spending who's spending it what
time of day
try to help you sort of uh be more
sustainable
another example are what are known as
ability-based interfaces these are
interfaces that are that can be
customized
to individuals say with different motor
abilities so imagine that i were
i was born with a motor disability
this system can start to take a user
interface like the one on the top
measure various things about my motor
abilities and then
uh predict a version of that same
interface
that would be more effective given my my
motor abilities
and individuals who have these
customized interfaces you can imagine
this being like a
web browser plug-in for example um are
about 25
faster makes you know 73 fewer errors
with these automatic adjustments so we
can start to think about how ai can
understand
um how people who are born with various
motor disabilities or
or or seeing or visual disabilities
might be able to perform or also as i
age
or as i'm as i'm distracted because i
have a three-year-old at home and i'm
working from home now because of code
covid19 uh you know all these
differences
um in the style and fashion space um
people are building technologies that
allow me to describe in words
what it is that i'm looking for i'm
looking for an outfit for a beach
wedding
um it needs to sort of look effortless
and breezy and
build embeddings on top of this that can
return
uh items that that match the query even
even though i may not have used exactly
the right terms think of this as sort of
a higher level search engine i don't
just say
you know breast dress dress with flowers
i say
uh you know a beach wedding with with
that's breezy and it and it can
can do this mapping here's another one
um this will be a bit of a of a short
video
if you're a visual designer people are
building ai models
that can understand where people are
looking so
you want a heat map that says look at
the red parts people pay attention to
the red parts
and as i move the design of my poster
around
let's say this text october um as i make
it smaller or larger
it you i can see immediately how much
people are going to be paying attention
to various parts of the poster
so now imagine i'm a designer or a
marketing person or something like this
being able to work in a very tight loop
where i can change
everything that i'm doing i can change
the design i can change the messaging
and get an immediate prediction of what
people are going to pay attention to
because we have better models of human
visual attention
so if i change the color no one pays
attention anymore
so there are lots of opportunities but
there's lots of
challenges in this space as well and i
think this is
where we're going to start to dig into
the court the core issues around
designing interactive artificial
intelligence
which is uncertainty and error
what do i mean by this so
in essentially up to this point in
computing and interaction
we've lived in a world in which when i
click on something or when i say
something
the computer does exactly what i ask
it's known as direct manipulation
that i say click on the save button
and the machine saves click on the bold
button
and you know my text gets bold but
people are trying to do stuff with ai
that will inevitably introduce error and
uncertainty
and that's because i might be saying
things at a higher level like
make this look more professional or it
might misunderstand me
or it might mis-execute it's more
intelligent but it's not deterministic
it's not
it's not for sure that it will do this
so what do we do about this
in some systems um when you have very
high certainty
that you just the systems will
automatically take action
so on the left you can see an example in
gmail if i said
um you know attached arm my tax
documents
but i didn't actually attach anything or
various other versions of this
gmail will actually pop up a window that
says hey did you actually
mean to attach files this is sort of
like the are you trying to write a
letter right now from microsoft word
uh but it's so certain given your
language
that this is often viewed as a savior
rather than an annoyance
likewise when i tell siri to set an
alarm
in 25 minutes siri just goes it goes
ahead and does it
when it's high certainty and the
probability of error is low it just go
these these systems will go ahead but
what if certainty is
lower what do we do and here there are a
number of different techniques
that industry and research have
developed to try and be a bit smarter
about this
one of them goes under the heading of
adaptive interaction
in adaptive interaction what you're
doing is
tweaking the interface to sort of bring
things
closer to you that you that the system
thinks might be more useful
so rather than trying to execute
something automatically
it's sort of more like um an assistant
who's bringing you the stuff that you
might need right at the time when you
need it
and you can notice for example that when
you resize
in this case microsoft word it's not
that it just sort of cuts
off the various items it will actually
relay out some of them
it'll collapse certain things it'll
expand certain things
because it has a notion of what you're
likely to be clicking on
and it and it will try to lay things out
such that it keeps the tools that you
need
most available again
you can think about being adaptive that
as uh you'll notice that if i take a
website and i turn it
on my phone and i turn my phone from say
vertical to horizontal
it will relay it out ai's will sometimes
do this kind of thing as well
where i can automatically re relay out
an interface
that would say design for a mouse
interaction to be
to work well with touch interaction like
on a phone or a tablet
by trying to optimize a cost function on
on how much time and effort it would
take someone to
to do this now so that you can be
adaptive like this but another
large set of options are are oriented
around accelerators
what are accelerators accelerators
basically don't force you to do anything
by default
it might just do exactly you might be
exactly as fast as you are now
but it offers you an opportunity to sort
of auto complete what you're doing
sometimes literally when i type sanf
into google this drop-down has lots of
guesses about things that i might
actually be typing and it's not san
francisco that's the most likely it's
actually san francisco weather
so all so all i need to do is press the
down down arrow and enter
and it'll it'll speed me up or likewise
um
the when i'm driving driving directions
like with google maps or
apple maps um or various others um
ways it will sometimes say hey there's a
faster route now available
and this is an interesting question
right i can i can be accelerated by
hitting accept or if i do nothing i stay
where i am
and there's always the important
question here of whether this is opt-in
or opt-out
if i do nothing will it move me to the
new route or if i do nothing we'll just
keep me where
where i am this is very
context-dependent in general you want to
my advice is to opt toward heavier user
control
which would mean by default let the do
the last thing the user told you to do
but allow them to revise their opinion
another approach that many interactive
systems use when trying to layer on top
of
of uncertain ais are suggestion this is
when you have
uh lower lower certainty these are often
seen
in the in the context of what are known
as recommender systems
recommender systems power everything
from amazon to netflix to uh to stitch
fix
the basic idea here is that it's uh it's
saying hey here's some stuff you might
be interested in seeing
so um you know netflix at some point
tries to maybe he thinks that i'm that
i'm into
uh comedies and it'll show me parks and
rec friends and cheers
or stitch fix is trying to learn more
about my style so that it's
so that it sends me genes that um that
fit my style
if you want to learn more about this i
would check out collaborative the term
collaborative filtering there's a rich
uh rich set of techniques around this
but ultimately what these what these
recommender systems tend to be tend to
be used to do
is to display a large number of
personalized suggestions to the users so
we don't know which one we might be
wrong about any given one of them
so we're not going to show you one we're
actually a menu
and and you're going to pick between
them the hope is that
at least one of the things there would
be good enough even if some of them are
are kind of off
and then in general if you have low
certainty you just do nothing
this is in fact most interfaces today it
does what's known as direct manipulation
it just says
the end user's in control we're not
gonna we're not gonna
screw anything up but we're not gonna do
anything either we can make guesses but
ultimately there's so much error that we
might make that it's just not worth it
it's just not worth it we're going to
let leave you in control
so this is overall known as a mixed
initiative interaction framework
and it's mixed initiative because
sometimes the computer will take the
lead and sometimes the the person will
take the lead
um if you're a little bit more um
mathematically oriented i can sort of
provide a visual
a visualization of of the um
of the notion here on on the x-axis
along the bottom is the probability
of of some goal being true given that
the the system
thinks it's true so on the on the bottom
on the bottom right there is
yep the machine is right on the bottom
left is nope it's wrong it thought the
goal
that your goal was g but it definitely
wasn't and on the y-axis is how much
value this brings to you this is in sort
of an economic sense like utility
so is it really good for you or is it
pretty bad for you um
so if it's unlikely that the user has a
given goal
we're on the left half of this square
and if it's likely that the user has a
given goal then we're on the right half
of
of of that square and you can actually
now
build out several if you could build out
a few utility measures
so for example in the upper left that
that little um
half side half of sideways half t
is is a not symbol logical operator not
if you haven't seen that before
um what it's saying is what's the
utility to the user if i take no
action and it was not their goal
so let's say it means if i interactively
do nothing just let the let the user do
their thing
um and and i was wrong about what the
thing
that they were going to do was and in
the upper right likewise is
the utility of taking action if it was
their goal what
what if they didn't want to change
routes and i did it for them how good is
that
and likewise the other two would say
what if i don't do anything but i was
right what if i do do something
and i was wrong that's the false
positive right what happens if i
if i if i say if you're writing a letter
how much how bad is that
and it turns out that you can actually
reason over this space to figure out
when you should do what
for example here this green line is what
you can think of as the utility of
inaction they both say not a that means
i do nothing
right so if in the upper left that means
if i was wrong
about the goal this is how much utility
i would be getting if i did nothing
and on the bottom right if i did nothing
but i was right about the goal
that's how much benefit or or harm i
would bring to the user likewise there's
a utility of action
and what you can start to do is say
where's the where's the line highest and
what you can sort of see is that
the the line on the utility of inaction
is higher it's in that upper left it's
it's higher up um when the uh
when when i'm low certainty on the left
half of the diagram
like when i don't when i'm not actually
sure i should probably not do anything
but as i become more sure then i should
start to act and you can reason about
this
in a closed form fashion uh through
through this this notion of mixed
initiative interaction from eric horvitz
now that's all what happens at the user
interface
side what happens about interaction
when we're really dealing in the with
the guts of these machine learning
models
what should we do what what what's going
to happen
so here we're going to dive into these
machine learning models these ml models
a little bit more directly
because these ai systems are all built
on the back of these modern
neural networks and
we have to understand what what we can
do to try and make these models
more powerful more effective more
understandable uh
and so on i'm gonna assume here at least
at a basic level you know what machine
learning is doing but if you don't i
think you could probably
figure out the assumptions that i'm
making
one of the core questions of this space
is
what is that black box learning you've
trained some statistical machine
learning model
and what has it learned how do i know
what it knows and what it doesn't know
what kind of errors might it make these
machine learning models are big black
boxes they're powerful they're very
but they're very high high level
statistical functions
uh that that that can basically they're
universal approximators which means they
could learn anything
but what did it learn so it's opaque
it's unintelligible
which makes this thing very difficult to
predict design and debug
and it results in some very
non-intuitive behavior this famous
image by ian goodfellow is an example
i built a computer vision underneath
what it's looking at
here in the bottom left is i feed it
that image of a panda
and it outputs panda with no an okay
level of confidence about
you know 57 confidence then
um these authors demonstrated that i
could add
a very very small amount of noise um
carefully chosen
noise that uh that is a messed up
version of a nematode
or excuse me it's gonna think it's a
nematode but be very low
low confidence in that and produce the
image on the on the right
that image looks to humans basically
exactly the same as the panda image on
the left
it does have this sort of high frequency
noise layered into it that
we but we humans can't really tell but
this totally messes up the algorithm
and now the algorithm thinks with very
high confidence 99
confidence that this thing is a gibbon
totally wrong
so two images that look the same to
people
the algorithm is thinking are very
different and so we need to be able to
understand
why did it think this way why did adding
you know this seemingly random colored
noise change its opinion
the goal here is to produce what's known
as intelligibility in these models
a model is intelligible um as
sort of as as is defined basically to
the extent that a person can predict
how a change to the inputs will change
its outputs so for example
uh let's examine whether my
three-year-old is intelligible um
and i was trying to feed him lunch if i
uh earlier today if i give him a
uh a peanut butter sandwich i can
predict that he will be happy and eat it
if i try to give him the lentil soup
that i made i can predict
that he will not eat it and will not be
happy so i feel that that model is
relatively intelligible because i can
reason about it when i change the inputs
to his
to to his lunch i can predict the
outputs from from his mouth
so for example in the bottom left linear
linear relationships
we tend to view is it very intelligible
right so um
y equals mx plus b if um you know if i
get more years of education then my
then my lifetime income goes up that's a
linear relationship it's just two
variables
um as i increase y you know as i
increase x y either goes up or down
convolutional neural networks of the
sorts that are used in computer vision
um far less intelligible there's
you know these these sliding windows
that are compressing down
and then recombining um you know
essentially
one cannot really make a prediction of
what happens if i change the little
circle on the top of the robot's head to
a square we don't know
exactly what's going to happen um they
they they make as we would say at the
end of the day they would make errors
so one way to to look at this from from
an uh
an intelligence augmentation point of
view is to try and help visualize what
the model sees
these are images that might keep you up
at night but
what it is is on the far left you can
sort of
essentially accentuate the
the nodes within the neural network that
are activating
with the with the notion of a labrador
retriever and
essentially get it to hallucinate what
it's what it sees when it thinks of
a labrador or receiver and then as you
go over to the right
a tiger cat and then you can uh build
the entire
linear space between those to look at
what what is it paying attention to and
as you can see on the far
left when it's when it's recognizing
labrador retrievers what it's really
seeing are these big floppy ears and
some brownish nose and so on
and then on the right with the tiger
cats you can see the small
pointy ears the sort of texture to its
fur the patterns on its fur
um and in between so
the i the question would be maybe we
can't make the thing reason
in the same way that a person can but
maybe we can come around the other side
and help a person
see what the system is seeing
now there are other approaches as well
just simplify the model
sometimes you can actually get you know
90 95 percent of the same of the
performance out of the machine learning
model with hot far higher
intelligibility
one of my favorite examples in this
space is an algorithm known as lime
um and what this thing does
is try to point out that even if the
the entire decision is complex
maybe within a specific with the with
the case of a single example it's much
simpler to understand so let's say for
example here you have these blue circles
and these red crosses
and the machine learning algorithm has
learned to separate the the red crosses
and from the blue circles
uh through the sort of lighter colored
irregular space that you see
here so let's say you were trying to
explain
why is this red plus sign
why is it in the red space why is it not
a blue why do i not think it's a blue
circle
what would you do well lime made this
observation that you could sample
points nearby for example these big red
crosses and big blue circles
and weigh them in proportion to how
close they are to the example you care
about
and then learn a very simple linear
separator between
those so you see that black dashed line
around the red plus sign says you know
what
i can't explain the the full complexity
of the space to you
but for this particular example relative
to other counterfactuals nearby
here are the features that matter what's
important to note here well let me give
an example
again my three-year-old when i say it's
bedtime
you can say why why is it bedtime i'm
not tired
i can give all sorts of different uh of
of different
reasons it might involve the fact that
he needs sleep
or he's going to become a mess it might
be that you know i need to do some work
tonight it could be many different
things and they might all be true it's
complex
space but in the case of
of this particular example the most
salient reason
might just be because it's after his
bedtime
and that's the simplest explanation to
give if the time were to change to be
earlier
it would no longer be his bedtime so
i've inserted a simpler
explanation but it's important to point
out that this is actually kind of
technically a lie it's not a
representation
of the full model there are times where
i would let him stay up past his bedtime
for specific reasons but i'm not going
to explain all that it's going to be a
local explanation
um percy liang and uh penguin co here at
stanford also did some cool work on
influence functions
that are another way you can visualize
this so in this case what you can do is
say well here's this test image on the
left and
you can start to actually identify the
training
images the inputs you trained the
algorithm on that were most influential
in the decision
so again here um with this with the
sense of my three-year-old
sending him to bed you can say why well
i can say well let me tell you
because when you stayed up late last
time
you were very cranky the next day so it
pulls
out the influential training data points
and those are much more readily
interpretable than a complex model
now as dan weld uh and his colleague
argue
there's actually a dilemma here any
model simplification like line
is a lie it is not true that this is
exactly how the model reasoned about it
we're telling you a single thing when
there's a much more complex set of
factors
in play here but it turns out that the
non-simplifications are just
unintelligible so we're somewhat in a in
a sticky wicket here
that we either have to lie or we have to
give you the full details in a way that
are going to be very hard to understand
and i think it's really going to depend
on your context
what dan weld and argues is that you can
draw on psycho psychology research to
guide
what makes for an effective explanation
so you make explanations for example
contrastive these are things that people
tend to understand quite well
well why did you recommend movie x the
implicit critique there is why didn't
you recommend
movie y and you can explain that much
more effectively necessary causes being
better than sufficient ones
using few conjuncts don't say it's
because of a and b and c
and d and so on
now when we pull all this together we
start to see
a situation where these ai techniques
are especially
common as we kind of move off the
desktop into voice
speech computer vision based interaction
because once you're off the desktop
you often require intelligence i'm going
to avoid saying the name of the spark
speaker on the left
in order to so that i don't uh say the
wake word of the the one in my room
uh but you can get the idea of what it
is um fitbit
apple watch all are all sensing my
biking right now am i
walking in my um soon the new version of
ios
will tell you whether you're washing
your hands um
the um nest thermostat detects
when you should when it should be
changing the temperature and whether
you're home and so on this all requires
artificial intelligence because we're
not gonna
sit there and and tap every button on
everything
and there's lots of examples where this
has become successful so here's an
example of a research project a number
of years ago now at georgia tech
demonstrating that you can figure out um
what kinds of
uh just like before when i was showing
what's using the water in your in your
in your home what's using the
electricity in your home or here's an
example out of carnegie mellon
uh demonstrating that by just simply
having a smart watch on
it can it can start to pick up on the
electromagnetic
waves being sent out by various things
you might touch and your computer can in
real time
detect what you're what you're touching
so as i
as i'm holding this iron sending
electromagnetic signals
body is as well smartwatch and that
smart
make sense of the signal run some
machine learning on top of that
and then uh detect what i'm doing so now
imagine
that my watch knows what i'm doing am i
grasping my office door it should
unlock the door when i'm grasping the
door for example
um and all sorts of other examples
so am i turning on the am i turning on
the stove am i get am i grabbing my
my toothbrush am i trying to open a room
am i using
my first laptop or my second laptop
imagine how our interfaces
might be able to adapt themselves if
they knew what i was
doing these are the kinds of
applications that become possible when
we go off the desktop
so i have just a few closing thoughts
and then we have
hopefully i left plenty of time for for
questions
and discussion and again as a reminder
there's a q a
area in your interface that you can feel
free to toss questions into
um and then you'll you'll soon be able
to see my face again and we can uh have
a discussion for the rest of the
conversation here so a few reflections
first ai is undoubtedly a very powerful
tool
but it brings along with it some
massively unsolved
user interaction problems and often
and there are a few different sources of
those one which
i which warrants uh you know an entire
lecture on its own
is problems around bias justice and so
on
that these models can can inherit the
one we talked about today
also important is the fact that all of a
sudden it takes
some something that used to be a very
certain interaction direct manipulation
and injects uncertainty so it brings
benefits in that it can do things that a
direct manipulation interface never
could
but it also makes errors and it's not
sure about what
about its answers so we have to think
about how to design
so the second reflection here that i
hope you're taking away
is that if we're if we're smart and
thoughtful about how we do the
interaction design
we can hide or manage that uncertainty
more effectively
that we can sort of build in a user
experience
that still feels good even though under
the hood it might not be entirely
certain
we also now know that if you don't do
that well as i'm sure you can now think
of examples
it can really cause someone to throw
throw the thing on the floor
and finally again quoting etana dar
don't let your artificial intelligence
write a check that your ui can't cache
meaning don't build an ai model that we
can't create an effective user interface
around and don't let your user interface
your ui
write a check that your ai can't cache
again meaning that
you shouldn't be having building a user
interface that assumes or promises
things
that an artificial intelligence
algorithm can't actually do well enough
yet
uh it turns out um through prospect
theory um
a nobel prize winning theory from
conomon tversky
that people are very very averse to
problems and errors
people will much rather avoid a problem
than than essentially get an equivalent
benefit
so if i have a choice between something
that's slower but will do the thing for
sure
or faster but might make an error many
people will choose the slow but sure
route
i think this is a major impediment in
some ways or major reason
why people are are avoiding intelligent
interfaces unless they're very very
accurate
so i'll close here and i think we have a
few minutes left for
conversation questions and so on all
right so i will stop sharing my screen
and we will talk
hopefully you can now see my face yes
and hopefully everybody can hear me
thank you michael this is very
informative and an
impactful presentation we've gathered a
range of questions from the audience
so let's go ahead and get started the
first question
is if you could talk more broadly how is
ai
being utilized to mitigate this
particular question with supply chain
disruptions during the pandemic
for example in the food service industry
transportation lodges logistics clean
energy or
any other industry what are you seeing
seeing what are you hearing
um out there right now
sure um yeah well not very well
for a very particular reason um and
again hopefully you can see my face now
um the here's the reason okay
machine learning inherently makes the
following assumption
it has training data and the training
data
is assumed to be coming from the same
distribution as the test data or the
real world
what that means is that essentially all
of these algorithms assume
that what they're going to need to do
when they're
put in the real world is exactly like
the training data they were given
so now imagine that your training data
all comes from a pre-pandemic world
you can make all sorts of assumptions
and now your test environment
your real world environment is a
pandemic
everything has changed and so many of
these algorithms will in fact i predict
making the wrong predictions because
they
don't know what to do in these sort of
off-kilter scenarios
um there's a really good example you may
have heard um
a few years ago there was a
google's alphago algorithm was playing
um
go master the world champion and
it did in fact win but there was a very
telling moment where
uh essentially the the player the human
player did something that the
the algorithm uh had not really seen
before it was a confusing move and the
system just totally collapsed and made
some nonsensical moves
so uh i would actually be very careful
about
uh thinking about how to deploy ais in a
world
that has changed because that's not what
they're meant to be able to do i
in in those cases i would actually be
much more uh
i would be much more likely to to make
sure that there's additional human
oversight
so that it's not making um unusual or or
poor decisions
great um that leads me thank you that
leads me into
the next question and and this is
actually a combination of a few
different questions
um sure how do we help ai to avoid
bias towards things like race
disabilities gender um where we know
there's there there's an
issue um how do we adjust for that
yeah well i think we have to be careful
that there might be
you know um challenging assumptions
bellying the question how do we adjust
for that
because it sort of assumes that um that
it's that that's
you know that if we could just get
something that performed that didn't
exhibit that bias that would solve the
problem and it won't
but let's let's take this in two parts
so um if you're interested in the very
uh
cutting edge technical work in this
space i would check out a conference
um uh it's the i'll just list out the
letters
f a t star or asterisk uh stands for
fairness accountability and trust
and then everything else around that uh
it's a conference where people really
spend a lot of time thinking about this
however as many have demonstrated
um there's no single really effective
definition of what
what fair means or what what bias means
so for example
you could stratify on certain uh
certain demographics and make sure that
your that your algorithm is not
performing
better or worse on certain uh
demographics than others uh there was a
subject of a major po propublica
article a number of years ago about how
the algorithm is used to
to predict recidivism um and used by
judges
i.e are you going to show up to your
court date if i let you out on bail
uh we're biased against african
americans or black people
and it's definitely true that we can
start to to build
um estimates of this but there's it's
actually very the devil's in the details
there and
there's no really good way to capture
everything about what we what we mean by
fair
um and so you end up having to pick one
definition or another and then
you're going to inevitably uh take
basically be missing something
um if you're looking for folks at
stanford who have been thinking about
this charade goel in the management
science and engineering department has
some
really excellent uh fairly statistically
heavy work
looking at um how we can reason about
these issues
that said even a perfectly fair
transparent and accountable algorithm
might still be used to advance
unjust causes right i can have a a
perfectly fair algorithm
that's yet still used by an
authoritarian government
to um you know identify people who are
protesting and go through them in jail
uh or or that is applied
disproportionately
toward people of color and i think
that's where
we need to consider we need to remember
that computing doesn't just exist in
some technical
you know magical world where where
ethics and injustice don't matter
but but in fact that that ai and
computing are very tied up
with systems of power and oppression and
we have to stop and think
okay what is it that this system this ai
et cetera is being used to do what's the
goal who's going to be in charge of it
and how do we how how comfortable are we
with that answer what are the likely
abuses of that power
and what should be built in the system
to predict to prevent it or should the
system be built in
at all you'll just be an input to a
human
uh who's been uh who you know maybe is
elected or something like this
great thank you um this is a
there's another combination of a few
different questions
for an inspiring startup or a company
that is never a larger company that is
never
implemented in any any ai
um where you know the general questions
where does one start um and then
getting it you know taking that maybe
you've
done some ai implementation uh what are
the new fields and which ai
are being is being implemented
sure well to take that in an inverse
order
um you know the first the first area the
first sort of business areas that
adopted ai were the areas that
were fairly computationally heavy that
sort of tech
um tech field because essentially
computer science majors were learning
machine learning and they said oh i can
work with this let's insert you know
smart
uh smart email uh prioritization into
gmail et cetera
and i think what you're starting to see
or you've started to see over the last
few years is the
diffusion of this into you know supply
chain management uh
you know everything else uh fashion
farming
uh 538 trying to predict uh
your political outcomes from polling and
so on
so you're seeing sort of a diffusion of
this uh
into um into other areas often it goes
by different names
in other uh in other business areas
sometimes it goes
it falls under the heading of you know a
data science team
but i i would say that there are very
few
domains now where that remain untouched
by ai or at least where someone isn't
trying
it doesn't mean that they've necessarily
succeeded yet but i'm
i'm i would be stunned to find an area
where someone hasn't tried to figure it
out
if you're yourself trying to transition
um you know there are
many people here on stanford's faculty
who are actually um
you study business transformation and
technological transformation and so on
um i'm thinking um my colleague melissa
valentine in management science
um and engineering who
has through several of her studies
pointed out that
there's actually very complex power
dynamics within organizations that have
to be designed very carefully if you're
trying to
turn an existing business into an uh you
know an ai uh
smart business um because
ai is going to change who has power over
what
um and i you know to be very concrete
about that
decisions that used to be made by people
over here in the organization
are now going to be made by by
algorithms over here in the
organization that are and those
algorithms are run by you know
other kinds of people and so what ends
up happening sometimes is that
it gets gummed up and if you're not
careful about this these people who are
losing power in the organization
are going to resist the introduction of
the ai because it's
sort of reducing what they can say in
the influence they have
um uh angel christine in uh and here at
stanford's communication department has
studied how this happens in
in newsrooms like if you're um like a
newspaper
in the us or she also studied in france
um you know they have different
reactions to these predictions of like
what's going to get clicks or how many
clicks something god etc
and you know it's changing
the values of of who's important and who
gets to make these editorial decisions
and so it can really go well and it can
sort of make an organization sort of
combust if you don't
uh if you don't manage it carefully but
if you can do that the other things that
i've heard them
mention and really i'm relying here on
their expertise substantially
is that well obviously you know you need
to uh
produce people who are very carefully in
charge of the data
right what is this data that's being
trained you need a ton of data to make
any of these things work
who's who's collecting it who's managing
it who's making sure it's available
who's making sure that it's clean
having clean data is surprisingly
challenging um
and then you have a group of people who
are modeling
building machine learning models on top
of that data
and who's telling you know who's working
with them to decide what to model and
how and when
um what is good enough mean what's the
error rate that is
okay enough to launch a product um
and so you know there are a number of
programs uh through scpd and others
uh where you can i think there's even um
you know maybe uh
anita can correct me i think there's
like a digital transformations program
here at scpd if you want to learn more
about that but there's
quite a bit to be said about how to
manage an organizational transformation
if you're a small startup i think in
some way easier um
you're luckier because you don't have
all that baggage um but i think it
it will cause things to look quite
different than a traditional startup
like a software startup
great thank you and yes there is um the
digital
transformation program which this course
is a part of
um and you can learn more about that by
selecting the
learn more button um one other question
and this might be our last one is uh
i thought this was a kind of humorous
but it's to the point
how would you communicate to a company
the users
that your ai is going to give you
answers that are not
100 correct
there is that error and and how do you
how do you send that message
so people have tried a bunch of
different things
generally the most successful technique
has been to hide it
just to decide whether it's good enough
and to
own the fact that it might make mistakes
um or to be in a domain where it doesn't
matter if there are slight mistakes
so um peter norvig uh at
google i remember him pointing out that
a lot of successes in modern ai
are in domains where they're sort of
like soft edges where it's okay
uh there are multiple multiple okay
solutions
so if you look at these things where
like gpt3 recently is producing all
sorts of interesting
um text and that looks human written and
so on
it's because there's not one single
right answer things can be a little bit
weird and off
or there are multiple correct paths and
it can usually find one of them
so that's one approach that that places
have have taken
but ultimately so for example like with
tesla's autopilot
there may be multiple correct paths but
there are clearly wrong ones that lead
to
like a crash um and it's and you can't
just
say oh i'm uncertain about this you have
to decide at some point am i going to
give the control back to
to the driver and say i can't handle
this and when would you do that
so um you know i don't think that
exposing confidence
values many algorithms you might be
aware of these of these sort
and exposed confidence values you know i
think i'm you know 92 percent sure this
is the right answer
those can be useful but i don't think
that exposing those
two end users get interpreted quite
correctly
the other thing to keep in mind is that
people tend not to associate the errors
with an ai that might be
making errors they associate it with
your product right again think back to
clippy in microsoft word
it wasn't that um there was a machine
learning
algorithm which there sort of was making
errors they're like no microsoft word is
dumb it gets attributed to the company
or to the product
so you know i would be very careful
um you know launching things that have
high error rates or again with my voice
assistant in the room
um i'm sort of surprised how much i put
up with it sometimes you know
they they misinterpret things all the
times and become and it becomes very
uh very frustrating even though it knows
it's uncertain
it still has to do something and and
sometimes even just asking me
oh did you mean blah is still seen as
annoying so i think this is this again
comes back to the don't
don't make promises you can't keep you
know if it can't do the right thing the
vast majority of the time
i would be very careful about designing
user experience around it
on the other hand if you have some
system
in which you know the machine is making
predictions and then there's a human
layer that's always
vetting those predictions and then the
only thing that gets seen by the outside
world is the vetted version of it
then maybe you could be more certain
microsoft
has a system called calendar.help which
is a great example of this it's like an
email address that you can
it's sort of like a calendaring
assistant you can say you know oh
um maybe cortana or whatever it's called
now um
please find you know find a time when um
anita and i can meet
and it it's for simple requests it's an
algorithm for more complex ones there's
actually humans in the loop
and you never know which one you're
dealing with it just sort of is this
opaque system that
is some combination of humans and
machines and i think that that
as an intermediary solution can be quite
helpful
and over time you're generating data
from the human interactions that
that's the human supervision the the
algorithm itself can get better
and the in the people can be focused on
continually on the harder and harder
tasks so those are those are some of my
thoughts there
excellent thank you very much and that
is all the time we have for today's
webinar
um michael and everyone in the audience
thank you for joining us
if you found this presentation to be
helpful in any way we encourage you to
share the recording with your colleagues
and we will send out an on-demand
version of this
with your friends or family or whoever
you think will find this information
useful
thank you for taking the time to join us
today and have a great rest of your day
you